大学1年生の時富山から牧師増母に言ってたんですけどもその静岡から定番の実家に
帰るっていうと気兼ねゴールデンウィークとかねず休みとかお盆とかいろんな
タイミングがあって同じ境遇の人がいる気がしたんですよテーマに住んでて大学です
どうかに来てるって言う人がいるんだと思ってそういう女の子がいたら一緒にね静岡か
あと今まで新幹線で一緒に帰ったらすごい楽しいなんとか思いながら
1回もそんなことがありませんでした肇社長でそうカットちょっとぐらい前に育てる
くれしたのでたくさん買ってくれひとまとめにして九段目クリスタルを作ろうっていう
ところをとったんですけどもう今日でおそろ爪が完成してると思いますそうかだよね大
貨物ねえちゃんと10日で完成て書いてあるので食べ動画当たってるでしょ果たして
ぷりったらどうなっているのかもう
あの年額
失敗してボールの選手ねちっぱいしてもらった手にしないでねちょっとつーか頑張った
からえーそんな10番100日間待たなきゃいけないとかないよね10日でば館で濃い
青が出なかった本当にわからないこれがお腹受け頭でしょ
あーこ wi-fi 版はんが大丈夫かできてるのかな
こちらです強い声ご飯こいこいまぁでもなんか周りはそれっぽい電車これ腐ってるの
沢山ってないよねルークだってと抹茶の和菓子づくりで失敗したみたいになりました
クリスタルだろちょっとねんじゃないの大丈夫だグリッターにポインターでていると
思いますしていきましょう快適で切れるなんだけど見ます
ん
[音楽]
どうやって来ずれてみればいいんだろう
こ
何じゃあちょっと触ってみようか一羽ぞ
あっはぁ
今火災観測あってエピたくて来たかったんだけど者としてどうぞ
固い固い固い固いこれはルーって水水ゆっくりとっていきましょうか
そうしてこれ期待的にはかなり緑っぽいですねなんか真っ黒になると思ってたんです
けどがっつり緑質問
[音楽]
何か見えてきている何か見えてきてるよ3没この
グリースたるな感じでこれこれこの四角い後神これクリスタルポイスでねー
[音楽]
ちょっとのコップ者取れない街近くまで来たのでちょっと作戦かいます
voodoo 待ってしたら死ぬさあ
ヴァッハウクリスト
ああすごいこれもざっといっちゃ良いのじゃないからそんな崩れないと思ってくれたら
おおっ
あっはぁ
広いれる
おおーー
まあまあ切ったんじゃないですかねちょっと1回ながらだしてみましょうか
出せればいいんですよ1引きでいけるまあきたきたきたきた
むしろグッズを揺するかっこいいのかすげーこうやってみたらすごさが分かりますね
バーター風もちゃんとできてるなーはなんだしこれ思えてみるとやっぱりちゃんとでき
てるんだと思ってすごいこんな
ちゃんとプレッシャーになるもんなんですかねこれけっこうすごいな感動する姉は
すごいなあ
めちゃくちゃカラフルなくれたら作ろうと思ったら思いの外透明な感じになりました
津南ってありますけど巨大たクリスタルと言いなんかこれ土台にくっついたみたいな
感じです
でもすごいでもしつつめっちゃ綺麗なんですけど何かを持っているちょっとクリスタル
ペースたらしてたらちょっと感動します
た誓いのはいというわけでくれしたらようやく勘弁したんですけどもとか金かかった
最終的にでもちゃんと完成して良かったです本当買ったいいですよめっちゃ硬いですよ
これ目今か言いますからあいや
me
あっはっ